- We have reached the end of the hour,
but I have one more story
from social media to share.
This is #What I'm Liking.
(rhythmic jingle)
(crowd cheering)
We've shared a lot of love this hour,
and to close the show,
I'd like to share some
love for our sponsor.
As many of you know, Pilot
G2 pen is the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
I love it, but I'm not alone, y'all.
Chris Grosse, an assistant
athletic director at Penn State,
recently post this to his
11,000 Twitter followers.
"You can only write with one type
of pen for the rest of your life.
Which one are you picking?"
The post had over 50,000,000 views,
and of course the G2 pen
blew away the competition
'cause this is how they do it.
(crowd applauding and cheering)
Let's get Chris in here.
He's watching on ABC23.
What's up Chris?
(crowd cheering)
- How's it going, Kelly?
Thanks for having me.
- Okay, I wanna get this outta the way
so nobody thinks this: you're
not being paid by them.
This is just what happened, right?
- No, I was actually working from home
here in central Pennsylvania.
There was a snowstorm,
and I was down in our basement working
at my wife's work from home desk,
and noticed she had an
amazing collection of pens,
and included in that was
my personal favorite,
the Pilot G2 pen,
and you know, I love how it writes,
I love the grip, and I love
that you can just click it
to, you know, pass the time
when you're in long meetings,
and, you know, I wondered
if there were other people
that had strong pen opinions like I did,
and so I laid out a
whole bunch on the floor
and snapped a photo and tweeted it out,
and the rest is history.
- Oh man, it's so fun.
Thank you so much, Chris.
This is super fun.
(audience applauding)
I'm liking your post right now,
(heart dings)
and that's not all.
- Thank you so much.
- Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to show you as much
love on this Valentine's Day
as you've shown them, so, get this,
they are hooking you up
with a lifetime supply
of G2 pens and a check
for a thousand dollars.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Oh my gosh.
A lifetime supply. Unbelievable.
- [Kelly] Look at the power
of one tweet, Chris.
- Oh, that's great.
- That was awesome.
Thank you, Chris,
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Ashton Kutcher, Chrissy
Metz, Bradley Collins,
Summer, Lee, and Mckai, oh Mckai.
Happy Valentine's Day, y'all.
Remember, love us all around us.
We just have to let it in.
Have a great day, and if it's not,
well, try and change it.